est ce qu on pourrait réfléchir si on
n'avait pas de cerveau est ce qu'on peut
penser si on n'a pas de cerveau est ce
qu'on peut avoir conscience de soi même
si on n'a pas de cerveau faudrait déjà
voir si quelqu'un n'avait pas de cerveau
et c'est le sujet de cette nouvelle
série way à une nouvelle série à chaque
vidéo j'en ai conscience
il leur reste encore deux nouvelles a
lancé après celle ci vous avez toutes
celles qui aura toute l'année celle ci
elle s'appelle les mentale fact et
aujourd'hui on va voir comment vivre
sans cerveau
alors déjà c'est exister le plusieurs
patients qui ont été observés au cours
de notre époque contemporaine et on
s'est aperçu qu'il n'avait alors non pas
pas de cerveau mais quasiment pas de
cerveau quelques millimètres seulement
lorsqu'on a fait les examens de leur
boîte crânienne c'est là que ça devient
intéressant
et oui ma petite dame parce qu'on a
tendance à idéaliser le cerveau à se
dire tout le cerveau est gros plus on
est intelligent d'ailleurs les hommes
ont un cerveau un peu plus gros que les
femmes donc ils doivent être plus
intelligent ça n'a rien à voir
la preuve en s'attardant un peu sur le
cas d'un homme de 50 ans qui était marié
il y avait deux enfants
il travaillait dans l'administration il
a un petit souci il a du mal à marcher
même quand il est agencé pour te dire de
là il va consulter un médecin en 2007
en posant quelques questions l'équipe du
médecin des équipes du docteur feuillet
pour être très précis il constate donc
depuis tout petit il est traité pour un
problème qui s'appelle l'hydro s'est
faite l'hydrocéphalie c'est
l'accumulation excessive du liquide
céphalorachidien à l'intérieur de la
boîte crânienne dire que dans notre
boîte crânienne ont un cerveau ok on a
une boîte crânienne
au milieu de tout ça entre tout ça il ya
le liquide céphalo-rachidien qui sert un
petit peu d'airbags aussi pour que quand
on fait ça le cerveau ce qu'au mieux pas
littéralement sas a amorti un petit peu
tout ça est bien lui il en a beaucoup
trop à tel point que quand il était
petit quand il était enfin on a dû lui
mettre un tuyau comme ça dans le crâne
pour enlever un petit peu liquide pour
faire une dérivation un petit peu
sympathique depuis là un petit robinet
non il a pas de robin et n'ont donc le
médecin pas fou il se dit quand il était
petit il n'y avait pas les moyens
actuels donc aujourd'hui on va lui faire
la totale
irm scanner etc ils font tout ça il
regarde les images et la bim pas de
cerveau par cerveau il n'y avait pas de
savon on a cherché il avait pas de
cerveau c'est peut-être le premier troll
d'internet c'était peut-être lui du coup
pas de cerveau et non pas terme alors
pour bien comprendre faut pas imaginer
que le tuyau que je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure était vraiment dans son crâne en
fait c'était un tuyau qui faisait un
mini tuyaux qui faisaient tous dérivés
à l'intérieur son corps pour éliminer en
fait le surplus et le tuyau c'était
bouché depuis 30 ans donc dans son
cerveau la marée est montée on peut dire
tu vois tout s'est rempli du liquide
céphalorachidien ça après tout l'espace
est plus apprenez des espaces en fait
plus à s'accumuler et plus les
structures cérébrales été repoussée au
port du crâne
donc c'est à dire ça se remplit c'est
comme ça et ça a repoussé toute la
structure cérébrale vraiment collé à la
la paroisse crânienne et là vous vous
dites waouh mais comment il a fait alors
la première chose incroyable c'est qu'il
n'y a pas eu de dysfonctionnement
réellement de son cerveau a par là cette
petite difficulté à marcher mais il
avait pas de pertes de mémoire
les mauvaises langues ont tout de suite
dit oui mais il doit l'être plus bête
que la moyenne et effectivement il a fui
légèrement en dessous de la moyenne
nationale qui est de 90 en lui l'un puis
de 75 mais il ya eu des cas de figure
similaire à lui il ya eu d'autres cas un
autre avec 1 826 à un autre avec 1 830 y
avait des surdoués qui avait ce problème
en réalité c'est là qu'on voit toute la
plasticité du cerveau le cerveau c'est
une pâte à modeler il peut tout refaire
on a longtemps cru qu'il y avait des
zones définies pour le cerveau ici à ça
ici et ça ici à ça c'est en partie vrai
toute manière on n'a pas fini de tout
découvrir loin de là mais ça c'est une
preuve réelle que le cerveau peut serait
adapté en permanence y peut se
restructurer c'est vraiment quelque
chose de plastique des tirades 2
modulable lors du scan ils ont pas pu
voir les structures situées au centre du
cerveau elle n'avait pas disparu elle
s'était simplement déplacé ailleurs et
restructuré différemment comme je vous
le disais c'est pas un cas isolé il ya
eu d'autres cas il ya eu un doctorat en
mathématiques a été consulté le
neurologue donnent leur beurre le dr en
maths avait accueilli 226 tranquille et
son encéphale était réduite à une
pellicule de moins d'un millimètre qui a
été situé juste au dessus de sa moelle
épinière
le liquide céphalorachidien de ce mec
occupé 95% de sa boîte crânienne
mais si son cerveau avait pas pu évoluer
par compte son intelligence avait évolué
et son humour tout il y avait eu aussi
une histoire comme ça d'un homme qui
était décédé brutalement en 1914 et lors
de l'autopsié je crois qu'il avait 62
ans lors de l'autopsié
quand on a regardé on s'est aperçu que
lors d'un accident qu'il avait eu au
cours de sa vie son cerveau avait été
réduit une espèce de marmelade avait été
complètement bousillé et pourtant
personne s'en était rendu compte c'est à
dire que toutes ces fonctions remarcher
le cerveau c'était réadapter c'était
modifié et il pouvait continuer à vivre
normalement personne s'en était rendu
compte même pas lui alors voilà je me
dis que suite à tout ça on peut arrêter
de vous un culte au cerveau en tant
qu'organe ce qui est important c'est
passé par l'organe sa taille etc
c'est ça sa puissance de plasticité on
peut tout apprendre à tous les âges
on peut s'adapter à de nouvelles choses
notre cerveau il est capable de tout
faire en fait et notre conscience et le
fait de savoir qu'on existe nous mêmes
de se reconnaître sur une photo
exemple le fait de pouvoir penser n'est
pas forcément lié au fait que cet organe
est cette forme là cette géométrie là où
une taille ou une masse plus ou moins
importante qu'une autre
j'espère que ce nouveau format mentale
fact va vous plaire il y en aura
régulièrement sur cette chaîne
la prochaine vidéo que je vous sors je
pense que je vais la sortir samedi matin
ça va être tout les résultats de
l'expérience moutons chèvres expérience
mentale que vous pouvez retrouver encore
sur cette chaîne si vous l'avez pas
encore vu j'ai reçu 30 mille réponses en
fait j'ai reçu plus de 30 mille réponses
mais je n'ai pas pris en compte ceux qui
n'ont pas mis leur adresse mail je
voulais être sûr qu'ils aient une seule
réponse par participant les résultats
sont très intéressants vous verrez ça
donc samedi à 11h n'oubliez pas de
piquer sur la cloche si ce n'est pas
déjà fait comme d'habitude n'oubliez pas
de laisser un pouce en l'air de vous
abonner à la chaîne et rendez vous donc
samedi à 11 heures je pense
ciao
[Musique]